what a fun morning ethel m chocolates
you know this it's been a staple of
southern nevada for decades world-class
sweets for millions now have tasted and
now they're hosting this weekend tasting
experience at their flagship store in
henderson so excited to have you on the
show this morning some of ethan's latest
offerings phyllis feyer the store
manager so you can say hi to her when
you see her at the store but we've got
her nice and early this morning to talk
about something that i think is going to
appeal to a lot of people we're talking
mimosas and chocolate what a fun tasting
experience so how does this work okay so
basically you can either come in store
or go online and book your tasting okay
and you'll come in and our associate
will greet you and bring you into our
tasting room to our beautiful selections
and the way our tastings go it's
actually a little bit of history and a
little bit of fun so we start off really
telling you about our site our history
what makes mars so special but then we
go into like a deep dive where does coco
come from ah good to know definitely
it's a very specialized plant 20 degrees
above and below the equator so only a
really tropical area that it comes from
and from there where it goes into our
main plant in mars in elizabethtown
pennsylvania we create our chocolate
there and then it comes to henderson
nevada where we have those luscious
fillings that you see right here oh yes
and if you guys haven't been and you've
got to go in because you guys do the the
nice little tour and the free tasting
and then i always end up buying so much
let's talk about the tasting itself so
we've got a beautiful bottle of prosecco
here and what you did you said you
filled each glass of the prosecco but
then it has different flavorings inside
it does so what we do is we pair
different flavor profile purees with our
chocolates and mix that with prosecco so
not only are you getting mimosas you're
getting four different mimosa how fun is
that so a lot of fun before we dive into
the chocolate i noticed this wheel over
here and folks at home i know you
probably can't see that but what it is
it's like a a wheel with um different
flavors on it oh good we've got an over
and over shot here and i know it's a
little tough to read but let's say
you were saying phyllis uh you taste
something that's fruity but you're not
quite sure right this helps you kind of
decipher what that might come from
exactly so we have our senior scientist
mark mackey he's in development research
and development and he created this
flavor wheel to kind of narrow down what
you're tasting because sometimes you'll
taste a fruit but you couldn't quite put
your finger on it yeah our palate's not
quite as defined as his maybe exactly
so you can branch out and see what am i
tasting am i tasting mango coconut
pineapple about the whole experience
exactly all right so phyllis let's
really quick dive into what you have an
opportunity to taste here give me the
first one what do we got so the first
one we pair our luscious creamy white
chocolate vanilla truffle with a white
peach puree and the reason we pair those
together you get your creamy and your
sweet together okay kind of like a peach
pot
okay and then i see that is this the
salted chocolate yes what uh is it
caramel or is it just regular it's
caramel it's our milk chocolate sea
salted caramel
we put that with exotic fruit which is a
mixture of coconut banana you've got
some passion fruit in there and that is
kind of a play on a margarita so you get
the salty and the fruity i think all
right so we're bringing another drink
all right last two now last two we've
got our prickly pear homage to our de
our cactus garden and that's paired with
a mango puree so you get the tart and
the sweet together all right before we
run out of time the last one and final
is lemon with lychee so you've got your
sweetness there oh so many good things
folks this qr code you can scan this
this will tell you when it is i'm going
to put it up on my social media pages as
well really quick this is for weekends
throughout the month of may throughout
the month of may and we actually just
started to extend it through summer as
well it's been so popular we added an
extra day so friday saturday sunday 12
and 3 30. wonderful okay well cheers to
brunch and mimosas and chocolates with
ethel m phyllis thank you so much for
being here i loved it thank you very
much for having me
okay stay